und da habe ich diesen ball im
basketball eine erstklässlerin ins
gesicht gefängnis leute kehrt freak ist
in seinem leben vom richtigen weg
abgekommen headley war das abitur machen
soll und damit herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen video mit am start
markant krank der leute hätten
willkommen zu einer neuen folge
zuschauer glaubt alarm für cobra 11
ich bin heute ein bisschen froh ich bin
bisschen aufgedreht wird noch eine
klausur geschrieben hat die sache
endlich abgehakt ich fühle mich als
hätte ich wie dein leben dafür sport
gemacht ich habe wieder leute die nach
vorne gesetzt wird nie passiert
tagtäglich wenn ich jetzt aber das war
echt peinlich wir haben vor dem aufgang
zum klassenraum gewartet zwei
freundinnen sind auf dem eis herum
gerutscht was ich wollte auch nicht war
es beim schützen- und in telfs
hingeführt
alle haben gedacht also das haben wir
richtig friedlich
fortan an die ihm im schulgebäude
heizwerken neuer schulen geben die neben
beisheim wird oder wo man im
sportunterricht zu dem gift für
wahrscheinlich für einfaches verwirbeln
in die eishalle reingestellt und anderer
auftritt hat er auch verdient ja ich
auch sind auch also links und formulare
wäre sachen einstecken können deswegen
mit einer beschreibung also bald die
nördlich von phoenix deutlich war
alleine zu hause und versuchen dann kam
ein paket und dann habe ich mich in das
engste handtuch gewickelt und das
handtuch hat nicht ganz in meinem bauch
gekommen und dann bin ich rausgegangen
ohne kleidung wurde handtuch dann ist
die tür zu gefallen und ich war auch
wütend
bald war dabei ging hat mich ausgelassen
dann habe ich ihm gesagt dass er
aufhören sollte dann war er nicht in
frage war das schon kumpel freund also
dass so eine beziehung freund oder ein
kumpel freund in jedem fall auf jeden
fall drastischer maßnahmen wenn sie zu
dumm für mich zu ziehen oder die ersten
schüsse mitzunehmen das eine sagen
solltest du ihn nicht die forscher
künftigen weil jeder besucher aus lassen
also der erste weltkrieg
das tolle ist dass ich war
ausgeschlossen der freund ging an ihm
vorbei und da hat er gesagt
der auftritt er hat ihm nur gesagt er
solle aufhören hatte ich mal eine chance
gegeben wirklich aufzufallen
er hat ihm gesagt hör auf und das wahre
automatisch nicht mit seinem freund ich
würde dazu sagen leute twitter zu sagen
ein ding was wir schon einiges mehr will
heute auf youtube anspruch der schlange
nicht mehr für unsere ohren erklang
anspruch an denen sich manche noch
entfernt erinnern
der von einer glorreichen zeit kümmerte
und zwar alles leute die nächste
geschichte mitten aus dem leben
gegriffen und zwar von einem mädchen
sie erzählt ich habe einen jungen über
ins programm kennengelernt sie haben
eine fernbeziehung geführt als wird erst
mal treffen wollten rannte ich aus dem
zug auf ihn zu und rannte um klarheit
alle leute schaut uns an das war
peinlich aber mittlerweile können wir
darüber lachen es ist doch für dieses
nullachtfünfzehn internet freundschaften
dingen kennst du diese video ist sich um
roh genau dass sie sich irgendwie am
bahnhof treffen und dann wird schon mal
irgendwelche älter und folgende software
vor allem kamera draufhalten dadurch für
die sich so rum und rollen rom auf dem
boden und 28 dann auch fort in dem
moment oder der bands junge mädchen sind
sie nackt sind und das regiert und
dirigiert wie man der regent leute eine
kurze vista genau an alle da draußen mit
denen ich eventuell immer mal eine
internetseite anfange bitte rette mich
am bahnhof mich wieso nach vorn um die
nächste geschichte liebe leute kommt
wieder von einem mädchen beschreibt
heike hemmer kleine geschichten ist nur
kurz für eine schule passieren
eigentliche bis zwei aber mehr oder
weniger zusammenhängen sie musste vor
wissen dass mein bester freundin ich in
der fünften klasse aus spaß gesagt haben
während ihr verheiratet und das team mir
bis heute durch jedenfalls ist er als
wichtige gange sind zirka drei meter vor
mir gegangen und ich habe aus spaß
nachgeschrieben fächer ziel ein warte
auf mich und gibt melkus und im gleichen
moment ist unsere ehemalige lehrerin
vorbeigegangen die denker natürliche
hätten was mit einer
aber das war nicht der für die rca eine
woche da rastet man ist die freunde und
ich vor der turnhalle gestanden und eine
von meinem freund den wusste nicht was
ein blowjob ist und jeder hat versucht
es irgendwie kompliziert zu erklären
kann man sich einfach nicht die trickser
jedenfalls bisher ohne zu schauen ob
jemand kommt gesagt habe das ist halt
wenn man etwas in den mund nimmt klammer
auf sie wäre bei dem wort ping ist
einfach total ausgeflippt
jedenfalls kam genau in dem moment die
gleiche während ich freu mich schon
erwähnt darum die ecke und hat mir als
ich gesagt habe
das waren so unmenschlich peinlich
vereine zwei dinge wieder dabei klären
müssen ob die effekte die geschichten
vor aber unsere aufgabe ist es zu klären
und auch da bist du ein mit wasser
wirklich vorgang ist und was man daraus
werden kann
nichts leichter andere batterien aber
redet hat vielleicht einfach nicht vor
lehrern so darüber was sie alles in den
mund nehmen wollt oder keine ahnung wie
schon mal irgendwo würde ich ihn direkt
von lehrer nicht machen uhrwerk es nicht
unbedingt
hallo frau lehrerin die freut sich
direkt was gemacht und so auf eine ebene
zu kommen wenn ihr von lehrern wisst
dass die abgeben sagt dass sie auch
abgibt die besten stücke von arch mit
dem ersten fall müsst ihr auch noch
klären sie wäre bei dem wort penis
einfach total ausgeflippt also ich kann
mir durchaus vorstellen dass man die
leute die irgendwie komparativ erzogen
sind oder so was also extrem konnte was
twitter selbst einfach nur unbestimmt
phase sind nicht klarkommen wenn du
sowas da ist wo ich mein ausgeflippt
kann ja vielleicht anwendungen wechseln
klappe infekten unterrichtet werden als
lehrer nach vorne steht und das noch
nicht sagen muss egal ich glaubte der
schlimmste moment weil diese ganze
klasse wird auf lippen
[Musik]
sehr gefreut deshalb schon mal sehr gut
gelöst die nächste story concealer von
einem mädchen ist der weibliche steht
vor einigen jahren als ich in der
fünften sechsten klasse war zu diesem
zeitpunkt stand ich auf ein junges eine
schule er war immer unter freunden also
hatte ich nie eine chance wirklich etwas
zeit mit ihm zu verbringen
doch dann der ausblick auf den gewartet
hat während einer schule übernachtung
war allein in einem raum wird nur einem
freund und spielte bei also lieb ich hin
und wollte mitmachen als er dann den
ball zwar verlor das gleichgewicht und
hat einen bauch platz schaffte
ich wusste nicht ob ich liegen bleiben
oder herausfinden was hat er denn
gemacht den ball die ausgeknockt oder
wie baby also erhöht ihr den ball zu und
ich verlor das gleichgewicht und fällt
auf den boden nach dem bauchplatscher
mädchen der fünften klasse wird auch
parteien es ist nicht sehr effektiv
gekommen jeder sucht als auch irgendwie
immer so viel heißt wie das format
aufnimmt und habe ich einmal in der
grundschule rather vierte klasse die
raben hervor auch irgendwie am bache
beispiel alles mit bravour und irgendwie
dachte verhalten gewisser auch hatte
dann bei den bayern halt irgendwie
verschwand und wohin geschossen so
damals war natürlich etwas in
megastädten auslosung ganz ordentlich
und er habe ich diesen ball im pub
gefallen nach kräften ins gesicht gesetz
dies hinten über in den sandkasten
gefallen stand da irgendwie und die
diesen hohen bogen runter durchführung
ist auch heute noch so richtig wo
zusammengedacht heisterbach mann
verlieben ist aktuell so richtig ins
gesicht die postautos die wahl genommen
in zürich zu schaffen die es uns so leid
getan sich der palatin bleiben man auch
wirklich liegt der von der suhler oder
größte kratzer walther jahr aber schade
dass damals völlig gta 5 gab zu selbst
wird dann folgten durch die gerichte bis
macht könnt das tut mir richtig leid in
diesem kleinen medel waldo wenn auch mit
einem schriftsteller vor die wände
erster klasse so umgebaut worden alter
meine kraft wenn ich sie vorbei sagt
michael maxen leichter werden kette
sollte die gemachte macht es wieder mehr
video ist was ich sehr gut fand der
erste link in der beschreibung des
formulars
bis nicht mal patrick mach mal wirklich
ein abitur nicht ganz korrekt von